nothing goes with halloween like
halloween for more than 40 years when
the weather gets cold and the dark comes
early michael myers has returned to kill
again we're ranking every movie in the
halloween series from the 1978 original
to 2021's halloween kills
the greatest sin a movie can commit
especially a horror movie is to be
boring while other halloween sequels
have failed more spectacularly than this
one they at least deserve extra points
for ambition the return of michael myers
coasts on its own concept because it
does exactly what the title promises
bringing michael myers back and doing
almost nothing else
return picks up 10 years after the
original film finding michael as he
wakes from a decade-long coma and
overhears that he has a niece it doesn't
get much better from there in this movie
lori strode is revealed to have died in
a car accident leaving a young daughter
jaime michael meanders into town to find
her with his old nemesis dr sam loomis
in tow with the mystery of the original
halloween long gone the return of
michael myers turns into a tepid retread
of the first movie why watch halloween 4
when the original did everything better
the first time around
if halloween 4 disappoints by being too
safe the rob zombie remake went too far
in the opposite direction it was a bold
choice to hire a filmmaker with as
unique a vision as rob zombie to set a
new direction for the series
unfortunately the result is an
overcomplicated unpleasant mess stuck
halfway between reboot and prequel the
film dwells on the abusive childhood
that warped young michael myers mind
before leaping forward in time to once
again recreate the original movie the
result is a film that's relentlessly
dreary and structurally unsound rob
zombie is definitely a director with
style but when it comes to his
filmography this is no slam dunk it's
certainly not a slam in the back of your
dragula
the curse of michael myers is so
compromised that fans would go on to
circulate an early work print version
labeled a producer's cut as a bootleg
for nearly 20 years before it was
officially released in fact the writer
of the movie revealed in a fangoria
interview that the curse of the title
started as a joke about the nightmarish
process of making the film this 1995
entry finds jaime escaping from a cult
with a newborn baby six years after she
and her unkillable uncle michael were
abducted by a mysterious man in black at
the end of halloween five michael chases
her down and kills her but her baby
lives and winds up in the care of tommy
doyle played by paul rudd in one of his
earliest movie roles tommy has been
obsessed with myers ever since surviving
the events of the original film and he
teams up with dr loomis to protect the
newborn the plot that unfolds reveals
the secrets of the cult of thorn a
druidic order bent on cultivating power
through human sacrifice their leader is
the man in black who is revealed to be
dr terence wynn a character who appeared
in one scene of the original halloween
that you almost certainly won't remember
this tangled drama leaves little room
for either scares or fun meaning the
most compelling reason to watch is to
marvel at how little paul rudd has aged
in over a quarter century i don't really
believe in age or numbers you know i
don't
the halloween series has a track record
of taking absurd sequel concepts and
taking them too seriously there may be
no better example of this problem than
2002's halloween resurrection the eighth
entry in the franchise begins as a
satire of reality tv with a webcast show
called dangertainment locking
contestants into the old myers house for
a night of scares
[Music]
the hosts played by tyra banks and busta
rhymes have prepared a number of spooky
traps for the players but the
dangertainment gets real when michael
comes home the first victim sadly is the
cleverness of this setup the movie
quickly devolves into an unmemorable
romp through dark rooms far from
resurrecting the halloween franchise
this movie puts the series in the ground
it also features a depressing cameo from
jamie lee curtis as laurie strode she
appears in the beginning of the movie
locked up in a mental hospital where
she's killed by michael myers in the
first 15 minutes
rob zombie returned to write and direct
his own take on a halloween sequel and
it was a marked improvement over his
first attempt no longer bound by the
obligation to remake john carpenter's
original zombies halloween 2 cuts loose
for a unique story examining the effects
of the previous film's traumas on its
characters loomis was trying to sell his
new book lori was plagued by intrusive
killer impulses while michael dealt with
surreal visions of his mother zombie
chose to shoot halloween 2 on 16
millimeter film lending it an
authentically gritty grindhouse feel
that set it apart from most modern
horror movies this decision played to
the movie strengths namely its
strikingly surreal hallucinatory imagery
while more psychologically interesting
than many other entries in the series
its big ideas are sadly buried beneath
uninspired violence and an unrelentingly
grim tone
what the fifth halloween may lack in
originality it makes up for with sheer
trashy horror movie fun this time jamie
lloyd has been left traumatized by the
horror she faced one year earlier she's
experiencing hallucinations that suggest
some kind of telepathic link with her
uncle michael who vanished down a mine
shaft at the end of halloween four the
real joy of revenge is in donald
pleasance's fourth turn as dr loomis who
gets more and more over the top in his
desperation to convince authorities that
myers is alive pure evil and coming back
to kill once more he spends about as
much time in this movie terrorizing
jaime as michael myers does
what do you think he's going to do with
that
the appeal of this film's teen cast is
unmatched by any other halloween film
besides the original decked out in late
80s fashion and talking about how love
makes your heart feel like it's made of
neon jaime's climactic flight through a
laundry chute to escape her uncle's
knife has more genuine tension than many
of the other sequel's kill sequences
combined it also gave audiences one of
the most bonkers moments in the series
in which loomis traps michael in a net
and beats him with a 2x4
john carpenter has always seemed to hold
mixed feelings about the halloween
series he said in a 2014 interview with
deadline michael myers was an absence of
character and yet all the sequels are
trying to explain that that's silliness
carpenter turned down the opportunity to
direct halloween too but agreed to help
write it in the interest of maintaining
some share in the phenomenon he had
helped create the result is a film that
continues the story of halloween as
directly as possible while still putting
in an effort to feel different to that
end halloween two ratchets up the gore
factor in the style of the then new
slashers like friday the 13th picking up
in the final scene of its predecessor
the sequel is set entirely on the very
same night letting myers loose in a
hospital in search of lorry with dr
loomis in pursuit meanwhile michael's
motivations are explored revealing for
the first time the family connection
between lori and michael that would go
on to define so many of the sequels in
the end halloween 2 is a movie that
believes it shouldn't exist but still
gives a valiant effort to give viewers a
good time it's not perfect but it's
something as carpenter candidly told
deadline i had to write the second movie
and every night i sat there and wrote
with a six pack of beer trying to get
through this thing and i didn't do a
very good job but
that was it
halloween h2o is undoubtedly one of the
silliest titles in horror history the
movie isn't even about water the title
refers to the 20 years that have passed
since the first two halloween movies
lori strode is revealed to be living
under an assumed name after faking her
death serving as headmistress of a
private school attended by her teenage
son john is it weird kinda but it's fun
what the [ __ ] do you think you're doing
mom i'm really uncomfortable with you
saying that well then don't put me in
the position john h2o is very much a
halloween for the scream generation with
extremely strong late 90s vibes from
josh hartnett to ll cool j to the creed
song that plays over the closing credits
despite all that h2o is a surprisingly
tight slick thriller that lets laurie
fight back when michael comes for her
son it's jamie lee curtis who makes h2o
worth watching not only is her
performance as a still-haunted
middle-aged lori compelling but the
story was her idea she recalled in an
interview with the los angeles times
that was how i pitched the movie
regaining the soul by facing your own
fear when the stalky becomes the stalker
i guarantee you the audience will go
crazy
after years away from the big screen
michael myers once again rose from the
dead in 2017 it was announced that
blumhouse productions had hired david
gordon green and danny mcbride to
reinvigorate the franchise for a new
generation the result was jamie lee
curtis's iconic lori strode being
reinvented once again as a survivor
turned survivalist this time when
michael came back to haddenfield the
final girl would be ready audiences
responded well to the end result which
ignored all the other sequels entirely
the result was the highest grossing
halloween film ever made up to that
point making for an undeniable
crowd-pleasing revival of the classic
horror series
gotcha
if 2018's halloween was the spark then
halloween kills is a raging fire this
action-packed movie brings the town of
haddonfield together with the survivors
of michael myers teaming up to finish
off michael myers once and for all it's
a gory and intense escalation of
everything the first movie in the
revival trilogy promised setting things
up for a conclusion in the planned
sequel halloween ends if you love the
halloween films you'll love how
halloween kills commits to fanservice
without betraying what made the 2018
movie work much like the original two
halloween films these new movies both
take place right after the other and
taken together they feel like one long
masterful exercise in escalating horror
the boldest thing attempted by any of
the halloween sequels is to not be a
halloween sequel the third movie tried
to pivot the franchise into being an
anthology series telling an entirely new
story about a different halloween night
the movie is actually about an ancient
order of warlocks but season of the
warlock doesn't have the same ring to it
it's centered around a company cult that
aims to slaughter children on a massive
scale with a crop of cursed halloween
masks the goal to get revenge against
america for the commercialization of
halloween and usher in a new age of
witchcraft despite being disliked at the
time of its release season of the witch
is full of clever and memorable moments
unfortunately it was subjected to a
disappointing box office and scathing
reviews from fans and critics and the
intriguing anthology concept was
abandoned
any list arranging the halloween films
from worst to best is doomed to be
anti-climactic because there's only one
way for it to end the merits of every
sequel and reboot can be debated but
there's no denying that the original is
in a class of its own no hot takes here
the best halloween movie is 1978's
halloween halloween became legendary
because it's elemental its teen
characters are charmingly ordinary there
are no contrived plot twists or
convoluted motivations behind michael
myers he's just a man in a mask who
wants to kill everyone he sees the
tension hovering over the movie steadily
builds until the killing spree begins
and it doesn't let up until the movie
ends with michael vanishing into the
night doomed to haunt your nightmares
for the rest of your days it's a
minimalist masterpiece that redefined a
genre by reminding audiences that all
you need
is one good scare you know it's
halloween i guess everyone's entitled
one good scare
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]